yep Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver are
both in this movie playing husband and
wife they work for the Lannisters Gojira
so Godzilla it's a new Godzilla movie
you know what that is Godzilla is a huge
monster eat trump's on cities and now
did we have a new movie about him but I
love most about this movies I knew
nothing about the movie I had seen all
of the trailers all I can tell you is
that it was a new Godzilla movie and I
think there might be another monster in
there that's all I derived from it
really cool going into a movie so
shrouded in secrecy just don't know what
you're in for
which could pay off or maybe disappoint
I don't want to spoil the plot for you
too much I want you to go into the movie
not really knowing so much about it also
staff the fun of this but the point is
at the beginning of this movie Bryan
Cranston he's like something's going on
the government's covering something up
you find out well they just might be
doing that and there might actually be
monsters in the world with this movie as
well as it does a good job at
concentrating on the human beings it has
more character development it's a human
movie it's not about the monsters it's
about that humans kind of like The
Walking Dead AMC's Walking Dead it has
zombies in it but it doesn't concentrate
on the zombies it's all about the people
who have to survive a world with zombies
in it Godzilla is much the same thing
Godzilla is in it but it's not about
Godzilla it's about the people who now
have to deal with the fact that there's
a big walking monster in the world maybe
a couple and they need to deal with that
[ __ ] however if you're going to make a
Godzilla movie concentrate more on
humans than Godzilla then do a good job
at making it feel like you are in a
world where Godzilla exists and monsters
are destroying civilization as you know
it like they're a real threat in the
real world this movie does do a really
good job of doing that
so it got to get props in this movie for
that in that it can kind of disappoint
also because let's face it you go into
this movie you're like I want to see
Godzilla tear [ __ ] up that's not a
ludicrous request for a Godzilla movie
but this movie doesn't really give you
that for a long time Godzilla's and look
two scenes in the movie even in a couple
scenes you're like oh [ __ ] it's gonna go
down and it's like is a special news
report my god that was very devastating
that city is just doesn't exist anymore
meg I wish you could have seen it odds
are you wish you could have seen it to
house like come on enough with the ball
tickling teasing for so long in this
movie you feel like you're on the fifth
date with the movie and it's still
giving you the [ __ ] you're like come
on you know what I really want and it is
undeniably a bummer but in that I did
like the characters and since
mostly about the human characters I
figured we should talk about them Bryan
Cranston's awesome in the movie right
out the gate he has a couple of really
emotional scenes I'm like oh [ __ ] this
dude's gonna kill it but he's not in the
movie that much and get the feeling
Bryan Cranston's in the movies so they
could put Bryan Cranston in the trailer
so you will go see Godzilla as if
Godzilla wasn't enough but yeah I got
sense Godzilla's not really in the movie
that much you need Bryan Cranston since
Bryan Cranston is not in the movie that
much you feel like someone is being an
[ __ ] kick-ass is in the movie he's
but good enough I feel like he was kind
of statuesque and emotionless but I have
known military folk and a lot of some of
them a lot of them not all of them but
some of them are like him they're like
Semper Fi
let's get it done you feel like you
realize there are like three less cities
in the world now do you care you give a
[ __ ] I will do use it you're in mode
right now and you just want to get the
job done like you say okay make sense I
can't really hold it against them I feel
like that's just what his character is
supposed to be
however when Godzilla finally throws
down you're like oh sweet and it is cool
however there's a part of me that was
looking at it I was like it's not as
cool as Pacific Rim it's more realistic
than Pacific Rim for sure comparing
Pacific Rim with Godzilla is kind of
like comparing Fight Night with Mortal
Kombat look once just made to be
realistic the others made to be not I
did like the fact that it feels like
these guys are doing [ __ ] and these
monsters are throwing each other around
into buildings and [ __ ] you're like that
things are dying it's not good for us
but it looks neat there were more than a
few moments in this movie Mo's lead in
the last fight of the movie where I was
like holy [ __ ] - that that was awesome
and it looked great it looked
devastating I'm just saying after all
the teasing leading up to it I wanted
this to pay off big did it go no it paid
off but not as much as you wanted it to
feel like if they teased a little less
in the movie then the end fight would
have been more gratifying when you tease
as much as this movie does there's no
end fight that happens that can actually
pull off what you want at that point but
you got to give it up for the visuals in
the camerawork I mean holy there were so
many times in this movie where I mean
example monsters are coming after
someone and the ambient noise goes down
and someone's just there appreciating
them not appreciating but they're
they're just kind of like I don't think
I'm walking away from this you can tell
they're thinking that and it just you
know zooming in on them and it's really
the camera work really good
cinematography really good directing one
of those movies you reflect on after
you're the initial like where the hell
is Godzilla and the movie kind of things
like when you're driving home you
thinking about the movie you appreciate
it a lot more but I go back and see the
movie yeah I would but I get my friends
to see the movie yeah I would and that
I'm going to push it to say Godzilla is
worth buying on blu-ray so if you want
to go into this movie seeing monsters
fight each other and that's what you
want to see from a Godzilla movies not
really about that so Godzilla have you
seen it what did you think about it
where he thought comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more